everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 2 36 of the ask gary vee
show
[Music]
you ask questions
this is
ask Gary B first and foremost happy
happy healthy healthy New Year everybody
is a really funny it's like raining but
it's the new year and we had this weird
like Monday off yesterday that I didn't
really like I still don't understand why
it was a holiday
seems like real soft culture and then
Penn State
Tyler's crushed they lost a stunner like
that made no sense in the whole math
game now like they do on the expand you
were 99.2% likely to win at one point
yesterday he's also wearing my ear buds
bite why I can't put my ear buds still
in your head oh you have a pair I'll
make it for you moving on up see you're
wasting your money wisely uh anyway so
we're doing the : stuff now you got
numbers you feeling good or you can
start on the first one well we've done
if you didn't catch in the last episode
is we've now changed the format of the
askgaryvee show and what we're doing is
we are doing a call-in show now much
more like Drivetime radio where we are
streaming live on instagram and while
they're setting up let me talk about
Instagram good you can hit call go ahead
try and see what happens
let's person's name Gio okay live on
Instagram people are putting their phone
numbers now we're just calling them
randomly please have your questions
ready hello miss culture again everyone
so the format with the with the live
show is put your phone numbers on
Instagram live we save them we call have
your questions ready because last time
we did this we were struggling with that
uh and that's what uh that's what I'm
doing so but I still want to talk about
Instagram I've been so hot on it and
d-roc when is the eBay flipping video
coming out I need to change it actually
can you record something real quick by
the way I just changed my mind it is 20
like it's 220 thousand $170 the 2107 the
$21,700 challenge means it's the year
2170 yeah I was like what the hell I was
like driving yesterday but anyway we're
gonna have a twenty thousand one hundred
twenty thousand one hundred seventy
dollar challenge it is my belief
askgaryvee show listeners and Watchers
that every person that is watching this
can make twenty thousand dollars and
twenty thousand one hundred seventy
dollars this year if they convert down
time that is [ __ ] time that is
either playing games on their phone or
who the hell knows house of cards or
even the askgaryvee show and convert
that into learning how to buy and flip
stuff from dollar stores thrift stores
and most of all the five to ten thousand
dollars that's sitting in every single
person's home in their basement their
attic there closet and the how many
pairs of shoes do you think you have in
your apartment right now that you don't
wear anymore good
that is $64 twenty-five dollars their
shitty shoes you got it you get ready
good
who is this Matt tell people are sitting
with real money complaining that they
don't have a thousand dollars to buy ads
on the internet or Facebook and then
it's sitting in their closet Matt yo
Matt what uh you are on the askgaryvee
show dude [ __ ] ago I am I'll talk about
it well good man what's up tell me about
you ah nothing I just graduated from the
University of Kentucky
very nice yeah well that is very ironic
can you follow Kentucky football yeah
yes for the most part yeah but I mean
they were I know I know but they were
the greatest
I understand the SEC is tough and you
guys are known for basketball however
just moments ago John Toth the starting
center for your Center for Kentucky
football projected second third round
pick just signed with Vayner sport
dude no way yeah II was just in the
office with his family great dude huge
yeah little fun fact for you brother
all right what's your question yeah okay
so um one of our first found you it was
really basically the main thing that
attracted to me to you was I saw a part
of me in yourself well you must be
amazing
yeah you're telling me
so one of my big problems is this isn't
really I guess a business question I
guess it could be but but well I think
we're gonna like confrontation occasion
you like it no I needed it I had to do
that that's why that's why I knew I knew
that you doing are you like are you like
me very aggressive in public settings
like content like do you think like so I
think I'm weird dude because like on
stage or even in these videos I seem
confrontational because I'm competitive
and aggressive but in real life I heard
of it the fire is there a hundred
percent like I'm did I know about it so
what's the question or you do think it's
a it's a weakness are you concerned
about it like what's the punchline um
I'm worried if I'm concerned on how you
deal with confrontation with people
whenever you aren't really sure so like
for example let's go right to the
details yeah I've had for example I've
had an issue before where a best friend
and my current girlfriend got into an
argument together yeah and it just like
tore me apart like I didn't know how to
deal with them yeah that so I think I
think what one thing that I'll jump in
because I want to get some other calls
in I will say this I think it's
important for the people so the people
around me know that confrontation that
has no value is a deal-breaker for me
like it was funny what raced through my
head which is both my girlfriend and my
best friend wouldn't have liked the way
I would have dealt with it if it was not
valid if they were just you guys are
young people like if it was just dumb
[ __ ] that we were complaining about
we're having real confrontation about I
would have levelled up the car I would
have had one conversation with both and
said why are we fighting over our trip
to Disney to get
like like if it's completely meaningless
I would have created the context that
it's meaningless if it was something
serious than I would have Ajay made a
decision on what I believe and the truth
is the way I deal with confrontation
something you should think about is I
think it's a strength to not want to
have negativity in your life and so I
deal with it with one conversation and
it's a one strike policy on
confrontation with me in a world where I
have 80 strikes and everything else and
if they're not able to adjust to what
matters to me and that then I just kind
of move on and I mean that by the way ya
know a lot of precision fair with them
breathe be fair be empathetic but like
literally unless you're madly deeply in
love and she's the girl that you have to
marry and if like like I'm very
aggressive with my friends I didn't lose
friendships over this by the way this
was a line in the sand that I created
and so people realize they had to level
up their emotional intelligence and
actually what they cared about if they
wanted to be around me I really
appreciated that mattered because so
much [ __ ] is bad if you're willing to
think about it that way or it's great if
you're willing to think about it that
way
I think wait I think it's dieted
ridiculous this isn't war people war is
in the adult world should they don't
they don't have the higher level of
thinking and I think what hey Haley Hey
really I mean I have real bad news for
you youngster but they're the college
mentality trickles into 30 40 50 60 and
70 years just because they're older
doesn't mean they're any smarter about
the way the world really works all right
all right all right man take care
let me see you bye all right any another
number um I mean that's it the rock you
know actually in these breaks on the
askgaryvee show as they set up the call
it's a good up opportunity for me to
like just not interact with the person
but add like the bow so here's what it
is my friends whether running a business
whether running a relationships one of
the things that's been fascinating to me
is watching the evolution of the people
that are closest to me including this
team like watching Courtney evolve over
the next year is going to be super
fascinating because I'm so aggressive
around the emotional things that I care
about like Tyler you care way less about
things than you used to right like like
you and you're pretty and you have that
skilled natural oh we got somebody okay
get your [ __ ] together youngster
you know but you have to iesous have to
now put things into context better than
you did even though that was a strength
of your self why you just can't even get
to it yeah it's just you just realized
what you should spend your time and
energy on what you should I love the
quotes I love the quotes I mean it is
you know there is that piece of content
I put out like 99% of things don't
matter and everybody hits me up in the
comments and talked about what like what
do you mean like that's what I mean I
mean like it you would be flabbergasted
if you gave a lot of thought to how much
time you spend on things that at a macro
level aren't bringing any value and and
I don't want to belittle the argument of
the confrontation that a girlfriend or
best friend at 20 arrey at 20 to have
with each other but I just nine and ten
trips yo this is Gary Vee and you're on
the askgaryvee show man thank you so
much guys for calling me you know
welcome what's your name
got got Rover meet it well it's a real
pleasure my friend what uh what can I
answer for you my question is when you
are setting up a startup uh this is a
pricing question when you go strictly
trying to compete when you are how do
you get that you know startup number if
you're offering services or or a product
just go try to be cheaper for it with
the competition if you have a better
product how what's your thought on that
yes
do you understand yeah completely I got
it all of it all of it my friend
like everybody always asked me Gary I'm
just starting out and I've got nothing
and no business should I this and should
I that or should I do this and the
answer is yes my man if you were
building a business that you want to
build and you want to support your life
and family and have all the riches that
entrepreneurship requires well then you
need to spend 18 hours a day is it a
good idea to have a better product yes
is a good idea to have a service at a
lower price than your competitors to
give the person that is actually
financially conscious the ability to go
with you yes is it better for you to
cold-call ninety-seven people versus six
yes is it better for you to produce
great content that reaches people
through virality that is better than
your competition so they know about your
service yes is it better to hit up your
grandfather because he's friends with
this guy who's got a business in the
space and you're trying to reach yes is
it better to put your phone number on
Instagram Live to get on the askgaryvee
show to get an answer yes everything
goes it just like a lobby or everything
let me give you a really good piece of
advice I'm going to end it on this never
say no for the other guy it's the best
thing I ever told AJ don't make a
decision for the other side of the table
of why they're gonna say no just do
everything and then let them say yes to
the thing that they like that that's the
answer I was looking for thank you so
much buddy my friend when you pitch
people mix it up sometimes come in with
a lower price sometimes come in with
bravado sometimes come in with humility
when you actually try to get 297 people
and you get 70 meetings you actually get
the chance to try 17 different moves if
you're like 99% of people and overthink
everything and have one meeting a month
and one that back you don't get the
chances to try the different [ __ ] that
might actually unlock what the real
answer was so you have to try to get all
the time to get your life they would
have in life if you have 97 chances and
11 people say yes
that's the game everybody's trying to
play a game of I'm gonna get three
chances and get three people to say yes
and then three people say no and they
[ __ ] like a bunch of [ __ ] yeah got
it got it thank you so much you're
welcome and that's it like like that's
the game like one thing I don't
understand so many of you were just
starting out your [ __ ] and your [ __ ]
fancy everybody got real fancy for
having nothing like this entitlement or
you're gonna have some perfect strategy
it's the grind you know if he's of
course you should come in cheaper it's a
way for you like when you have no
reputation to get the gig including free
do you rock coming to you charge me for
the first video yeah bang that's it you
know
Annie's mom was making fun of him for a
salary like you know what I mean like
that said you got a grind right and my
friends made fun of me for my salary in
my 20s and 30s you work all the time I
make more money you now what dick look
like great you've won 1999 Congrats
hello this is Gary Vaynerchuk you're on
the askgaryvee show
hey Gary it's all oh um well how are you
I'll do it awesome thank you so much for
everything that you're doing and my
question is actually in regards to them
your mother and the self-confidence that
you yes you yesiree children yes and if
you can give me I don't know quick three
yep things to help build their
self-confidence I'd appreciate it
so here's you know I'm really trying to
figure out this answer so let me give
you like just a whole like diarrhea of
the mouth of like the things that run
through my mind okay okay yeah the first
thing my mom did I'll talk about things
my mom did and I'll talk about some of
the ways I interpret it now that I have
other things that I've looked at and
thought about having my own kids she
over exaggerated when I did very kind
and noble things like when I opened the
door for a woman at McDonald's I'll
never forget this in North Brunswick
when I opened the door for this woman
when I was like eight and like was just
being polite and like she treated it as
if I won the Nobel Peace Prize so she
went ballistic over the top on me being
kind and empathetic and respectful
and so that was huge um the other thing
she did was she never did that though
when it was an actual life thing
so like when my baseball team lost my
baseball team lost when I got these in
FS on my report card even though she
knew I was going to be successful she
punished me so she didn't give out
eighth place trophies in a world where
that would be the way the world worked
right right but she just genuinely made
me feel like I was unstoppable and like
was capable of anything that I wanted to
do and she believed it and because she
believed it and she instilled it
constantly it was constant offense right
and so I just think that you need to
look at your three kids you need to
audit them you need to figure out what
they're strong at and you need to make
98% of the conversation around the
things that they're strong at awesome
instead of doing what almost most what
every other parent does which is spend
85% on the 2% or not spend 98% on what
they are loved it awesome every parent
worries about some kid trying like you
need to be better at math Sally know she
doesn't like like do you know what I
mean like she needs to be capable like
you'd probably like your kids to be able
to count right right but they don't need
to be a [ __ ] geometry Wiz especially
if they gravitate towards humming twenty
eight hours a day do you know what I
mean yeah
you got so lewdly like do me a favor
don't listen to the biggest thing that
hurts parents is they listen to other
parents they listen to other teachers
they listen to the market and those
people don't know your kids right it's
you and your kids against the world do
you understand right and too many
parents think it's the world versus
their kids right yeah
so that's it audit them really try to
figure them out and don't think of
cliches of like if they spend all their
time on the phone good news the phones
the future of the way everything
like do you know I mean absolutely but
make them respect if you're going to
give them that gift of tripling down on
their strengths and allowing them to
flourish in that world make them respect
the alternatives they don't the pander
to it but they under have to understand
why it exists some kids need school
structure some kids aren't going to be
wizkid entrepreneurs like some kids path
is to become a lawyer and make a hundred
thirty thousand a year
some kids cheese some kids are just
gonna make forty thousand a year and
work at warmer and that's okay too but
they need to get a high school degree to
get that job like no your kid and make
every one of your kids feel great about
what they're gonna be AJ felt great
because he was the best student in the
family I felt great because I was the
most entrepreneurial and charismatic my
sister felt great because she was
absolutely the feistiest and had the
strongest will like make them feel great
about their thing don't make them feel
bad that they're not the star athlete or
the nerdiest or can make money just just
build self-esteem yeah let them teach
you a hundred percent gonna but as long
as long as they understand like you know
checks and balances got it
yeah gossip I love you Seri you're
welcome what about good what's that cool
let me get bang out to one more question
we'll do a four-person one so far big
shout out to everybody in the community
the fact that everybody's getting right
into their questions I think we're gonna
get our cadence down with this I'm gonna
figure out how to do the gaps in between
the years and I think I'm a nice little
show it's good I like this you like this
bless you
it's good right who's this hello hey
this is Gary Vaynerchuk and you're on
the askgaryvee show
oh what's up you what's up you know Gary
what's your name Roberto Roberto real
pleasure man what can I answer though so
I got a quick question um I started
detailing here in New York it's going
really good
it's detailing like car stopping me yeah
okay keep going like you know I did I
deal with a lot of high-end cars doing
coatings and stuff like that yep and
it's really grown quickly the only thing
is during the winter it slows down a lot
so I was trying to how old are you
figure out how I I'm 26
are you married no good go to Florida in
the summer
in the winter okay I've thought about
that also but don't think I'll have a
lot of clients over here
well of course build clients in Florida
now I've thought about like - trying to
attack other things by the way that's
four by the way that's and here's what's
the great thing about this show and
having a call-in show like if this was
just something we took from Twitter
that'd be my answer and we don't move on
our merry way but this is why I like the
call-in because let's keep talking do
you want to do see listen flip [ __ ] on
eBay and Craigslist and Etsy you can
make 50k like like I don't know like
like it depends if you want to triple
down on your detailing capabilities
build a brand during the winter months
in Arizona or Florida and actually go
down there and live in an air B&B at
first or whatever and figure it out and
hustle and grind the same way did if you
are okay with having other
entrepreneurial things during those
winter months you're more than welcome
to I don't know start a snow removal
business or a winter landscaping
strategy business or or buying stuff at
the dollar store and flipping it for 9
bucks and like the truth is reverse
engineer yourself if it's going really
well
a couple things are going the word of
mouth is kicking in which means that you
actually detail very well and you have
that skill I mean do you love detailing
know what they do know but they you do
really love it no yeah I really do so
dude I've got to be honest ignore Obama
so let me tell you Roberto I think a lot
of people don't think macro enough and
it doesn't even cross their mind to
actually go live somewhere else for four
months of the year I know how that's
weird
but in the days of Airbnb and the days
of Craigslist and a day now these were
decisions that were made years ago
pre-internet when it was hard to have
somebody live in your house for four
months and you had a mortgage like you
can do do you know that you could
actually if you were really good at this
and if you watch it if you're here right
now that means you're paying attention
to me let me give you a real good you do
rent an apartment to you like what's
your living situation yeah right now
dude dete the fact that you could
probably rear end your apartment to
somebody for four months using Airbnb or
other things I know there's laws and all
that but stick with me here what do you
live all right gotta be okay so like the
fact that you could do that take the
profit and then pay for your living
situation in a warm weather place where
the numbers are different
that covers your entire cost and it's
all upside for you to grind and continue
your craft 12 months here do you know
good that is yes I've actually been
thinking about that but never took
action on it
yeah dude why do you think so many
people lose everybody's got comments
it's real fun to leave your two [ __ ]
cents on my Instagram post how about the
people that are actually doing [ __ ] yeah
so [ __ ] go alright no don't go right
be like will you promise me as a man
handshake - handshake over a telephone
call that you're gonna do it oh
definitely I definitely will I've had
plans already have been thinking about
it I've been following other people so I
mean it's definitely something I've
thought about but what lovely actually
know what now now I've got vested
interest I've got emotional about this
what's been holding like be straight
honest with me what has held you back
from doing it
is that what helped me back was me
trying to build it here like even more
like getting more glass out getting into
a bigger shop and I've also been working
with trying to move that into houses the
code you basically protects like the car
it's like a glass holder one secured I
see yeah what they do is that it's
uninstall that in houses so that's what
I'm trying to listen you're not right
now by the way no wonder I'm not against
that either I mean just weigh the
options of like take this winter we're
in it now like hang up the phone and get
to action make a binary decision are you
going all in on trying to go to houses
and like work your ass off knocking on
doors trying to get people to do it
running Facebook ads or are you going to
get down to Florida or Arizona on
February 1st and take 3 months and do it
there just make a decision do me a favor
just don't think think one time for one
hour make a decision and go we got it
all right brother Darfur will regard I'm
telling right now I'm saving this phone
number I'm gonna track you if I [ __ ]
see your ass pondering on February 17th
I'm gonna lose my shin all right I'm
gonna block you to not allow you to
consume anything I put out you got
alright brother
I like this shell 236 guys
episode 236 in the bag you keep asking
questions
I'll keep answering them phone calls the
call-in show is well underway this is
how we now do askgaryvee have a great
great great great 2017 good I don't want
to intro with this format just go rent
[Music]